das weltraumteleskop hubble hat die
ältesten galaxien entdeckt es sind damit
die ersten galaxien die in unserem
universum entstanden sind klicks um
science-fiction
eigentlich sind sie gar nicht zu sehen
das licht das sie aussenden ist viel zu
schwach und zudem werden sie von viel
näheren galaxien verdeckt aber da hilft
die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
gravitation lichtstrahlen ab und so
wirken galaxien und galaxienhaufen wie
linsen die licht von objekten hinter
ihnen sichtbar machen und 13 milliarden
jahre war das licht zu uns unterwegs und
das bedeutet dass es erst relativ kurz
nach dem urknall ausgesendet worden ist
zudem leuchten diese uhr galaxien sehr
schwach zitat tatsächlich sind diese
galaxien licht schwächer als alle
anderen objekte die sich zuvor in den
tiefen hubble aufnahmen zeigten so
johann richard astronomen des ops
erzeugung in lyon das
hubble-weltraumteleskop macht
unglaublich viele aufnahmen kleiner
vergleich um alle informationen die das
hubble teleskop in den letzten 25 jahren
übermittelte speichern zu können
bräuchte man mehrere tausend julia blu
rays die datenmenge entspricht nämlich
weit mehr als 100 terabyte also
aufnahmen macht das weltraumteleskop
hubble noch löcher und die jetzt
entdeckten galaxien auf den aufnahmen
senden lichtstrahlen aus die etwas ganz
besonderes darstellen jetzige entdeckung
ist so außergewöhnlich da die
ausgesendeten lichts strahlung beinahe
so alt ist wie das ereignis des urknalls
selbst und das fand ja vor 13 8
milliarden jahren statt
wie konnte man jetzt solche
lichtstrahlen aufnehmen das ist zudem
sehr problematisch weil diese galaxie
nur sehr schwach leuchten und damit sehr
schlecht aufzuzeichnen sind es hat etwas
geholfen und zwar der
gravitationslinseneffekt ich hab's ja
schon mal am anfang erwähnt
große massen krümmen zeit und raum und
für uns menschen auf der erde ist dieser
effekt manchmal super hilfreich denn die
linse die durch die gravitation entsteht
wirkt als lupe objekte die sich hinter
dieser lupe befinden wenn extrem stark
vergrößert hinter der lupe befanden sich
genau diese uhr galaxien die jetzt
entdeckt wurden also hinter galaxien und
galaxienhaufen
das waren allerdings nicht vier oder
fünf galaxien sondern einige mehr
insgesamt hat man das licht von rund 250
galaxien aufspüren können
all diese uhr galaxien sind vor rund 13
2 bis 12,9 milliarden jahren entstanden
den forschern der eidgenössischen
polytechnischen hochschule in lausanne
ist es also wortwörtlich gelungen in die
vergangenheit zu schauen so weit in die
vergangenheit wie bisher noch niemand
noch nie wurden so alte objekte
beobachtet mithilfe des vorhin
beschriebenen gravitationslinsen effekt
erhoffen sich die wissenschaftler noch
viel weiter in die anfänge unseres
sonnensystems schauen zu können zitat
damit wirken sie wie starker natürliche
teleskope die uns ermöglichen die erste
generation von galaxien im universum zu
suchen und zu studieren berichtete jean
paul kneipp zeit dafür haben die
experten noch das frontier science
program im zuge dessen diese entdeckung
gelungen sind wird noch bis 2018 laufen
klingt also schon wirklich spektakulär
was da noch zu erwarten ist bis dann
bleibt dran und schaut euch das nächste
video an und jetzt kommt